december 4th
1969.
akua and jerry was 19 years old
and sleeping next to her fiance the
illinois black panther party chairman
fred hampton the next thing i remember
was someone in our room
shaking chairman fred chairman chairman
wake up wake up plaster was flying
off the ball you could smell the
chordite from the gunshot
if you've ever been under gunfire five
minutes it's five hours
to you it seems like forever the
shooting started back again
then another voice unfamiliar to me said
he's good
now i knew they were talking about
chairman fred
fred hampton was murdered by his
government
[Music]
but before that he was a leader in a
movement
practicing a new kind of activism
a movement targeted because of its power
to unite people
1964 has a historic year in race
relations
on july 2nd president johnson signed
into law of a civil rights act
it was the strongest in the 1960s racial
progress in the u.s
was at a turning point activists won
major civil rights victories and the era
of jim crow laws came to an
end but
at the end of the decade there were
still deep social and economic gaps for
black people across the country
black americans continued to face high
poverty
poor housing and unemployment and they
still had little to no political
representation
these disparities and an increase in
brutal police violence
led to uprisings across the country
many young black activists grew
frustrated
that the changes they'd hoped for hadn't
come
it's just the opposite of being a white
man
that's about the best i can abbreviate
that fight
after the police killing of an unarmed
black teen in san francisco
two activists in oakland california
bobby seal and huey p
newton founded what was initially called
the black panther party for self-defense
newton had studied law and knew it was
legal to carry arms in california as
long as they were not concealed
the panthers began to patrol their
communities
as the movement grew several highly
publicized confrontations with police
would bring about mainstream awareness
of the black panther party
the allegations in these confrontations
were serious
but the public accounts of them were
typically one-sided and shaped largely
by police
media coverage depicted party members as
a caricature of black militancy the
black panther party was
portrayed as a marauding gang they say
their goal was to kill all the white
people
in reality the panthers did call for
radical change
what they were hoping for was a
revolution a revolution to overthrow the
capitalist enterprise
but what they called revolution might
not actually sound
so radical today focused on socialism as
a way of solving
economic means they look to places like
canada which always had a democratic
political system
but the economic system has always been
socialism they want a democratic
socialist
country here in the united states which
they saw was a more equitable
more humane system they released a
10-point plan for broad social reform
that called for an end to police
brutality and
for black employment housing education
and freedom from prison and jails
chapters began forming across the
country
they started to implement social
programs which they called
survival programs the panthers would say
put that theory into practice if you
really want to change minds
and you really want to meet the people
where they are you have to give them the
services which they need
the programs included food and clothing
drives
free health clinics and sickle cell
disease testing
and were funded largely by volunteers
and donations from businesses
one of their biggest programs was a free
breakfast for children initiative
here we are living in 1966 67
is the most wealthy nation in the world
and kids were going to school hungry
especially african-american communities
so one of the first community service
programs were free breakfast
for school children and all the children
had to do was come
it was during this time that akua and
jerry
then known as deborah johnson met fred
hampton
i was a student at wright city college
and chairman fred
had come up to the school to speak and
he said at the breakfast program we're
feeding over 3 000 children a week we're
serious about
making power to the people of reality
we're not just sitting up here jaw
jabbing and talking [ __ ] you know
we about work and i said damn
he's serious about this business fred
hampton grew up
in maywood illinois just west of
downtown chicago
he became president of his local naacp
youth council
in 1967 at 19 years old
shortly after he was recruited by a
founder of the illinois chapter of the
black panther party
because of his charismatic skills he
quickly rise
to the top of the crop here he is at age
21 building and leading the illinois
chapter black panther party
soon after they met and jerry and
hampton became a couple
anybody that has met him or heard him
speak
they say he wasn't [ __ ] he was for
real you got to understand
that jesus christ if your dad a struggle
you better win and you did not discover
this goddamn that you don't deserve to
win
let me send peace to you if you're
willing to fight for it
chicago in particular was a place where
the party's ideals especially resonated
it was then the second largest american
city and
due to decades of discriminatory
policies also one of the most
segregated chicago's mayor at the time
richard j daly opposed neighborhood
integration
and in the 1950s the city had begun to
redevelop certain neighborhoods
pushing low-income residents out and
into densely packed
high-rise public housing in already
overcrowded neighborhoods
black people were pushed primarily to
the south and west side of chicago
a large puerto rican population was here
in lincoln park
and poor white people were concentrated
here in uptown
these groups all faced similar problems
they all had the lapradega schools they
all had dilapidated homes
they were all being drafted into vietnam
very few of those communities had health
care
in 1969 hampton led the panthers towards
an unexpected alliance
a coalition of activists working across
racial lines
against a corrupt city government that
threatened their communities
we're going to fight racism racism
what they had in common was their
poverty so they was building a
revolution based on class solidarity
that transcends race that they all had
the same hell to pay
hampton named the group the rainbow
coalition
it included the black panthers a puerto
rican group called the young lords
and a group called the young patriots
made up of largely poor white migrants
from appalachia
who had moved to chicago seeking
economic opportunity we don't hate the
[ __ ]
white people we hate the oppressive
whether he be white black brown or
yellow
i don't mean seeing kumbaya and make a
quilt i'm talking about
bringing them together on common things
they could unite on not
everything but who could say that
children do not
deserve to have a healthy meal if we
work with anybody from coalition with
anybody
that has revolution on their mind we're
not a racist organization because we
understand
that racism is an excuse used for
capitalism
hampton and other panthers helped the
young lords
and young patriots launch their own
social programs
they organized protests together and
it was working members were traveling
across the country to organize rainbow
coalition chapters
particularly where black panther
chapters were but also in these rural
white communities as well
to bring the revolution to bear this
blows people's minds
these people are not supposed to get
along but here they are operating as
brothers of the struggles as
revolutionaries against the capitalist
structure
and that was the threat to the state at
the local level but also
at the national level in 1968
the fbi had sent around this internal
memo
it outlined goals to prevent the
coalition
of militant black nationalist groups and
prevent the rise of a messiah who could
unify
and electrify the militant black
nationalist movement
it wasn't written about hampton
specifically but
by 1969 chairman fred hampton
was the one that fit the bill the
revolution was in the air
and the ways in which the panthers able
to transcend those racial lines
especially charismatic leadership but
one like fred hampton they saw him as a
greater threat a greater threat even
than
martin luther king or malcolm x ever was
in one fbi memo
about the black panthers breakfast
program they claimed their real purpose
was to poison minds with anti-white
propaganda
and indoctrinate youngsters in hate and
violence
the fbi under the leadership of jade
edgar hoover had deemed the black
panther party
as the number one threat to the internal
security of this country
the fbi operated a counter-intelligence
program
called cointelpro it was a program that
targeted dissident political groups in
the u.s
their methods typically went outside the
law
they were using tactics such as
assassination
discrediting false narratives
they were falsely putting people in
prison and exile which were all illegal
several black panthers were killed or
imprisoned
including the party co-founders in
chicago
the party was also targeted by mayor
daley and the chicago police
our office was burned down at least
three times people would disappear
you never see their bodies again before
you go to bed and i say i am a
revolutionary make that the last word
in case you don't wake up then somebody
might believe it and you might you know
end up in
what they call a revolutionary happy
hunting ground
hampton a rising star at just 21 years
old
knew he was a target too he'd been
arrested in 1968 for allegedly robbing
an ice cream truck
and handing out 71 dollars of ice cream
in 1969 he was sentenced to two to five
years
in prison he appealed and was released
on bond
but lost the appeal he'd have to return
to prison
by december 6.
on december 4th around 4 a.m
14 chicago police officers arrived
outside hampton's apartment
on chicago's west side inside
hampton and jerry and seven other
panthers
were asleep i was very pregnant
and the first thing i remember was
chairman fred had fell asleep while
talking on the phone
the next thing i remember was someone in
our room
start shaking chairman chairman wake up
wake up the pigs are vamping
and i'm seeing chairman fred look up
and then he laid his head back down real
slow
officers kicked open the door and shot
mark clark
a visitor from another party chapter
they
shot a sleeping 18 year old named brenda
harris
then they shot in the direction of
hampton's bed
going you matthews feel the bullets
going into it
i had moved over on top of chairman fred
because there was shooting into our
mattress
the person that had come into the room
kept shouting stop shooting stop
shooting we have a pregnant assist in
here
eventually the shooting stopped and
jerry was forced into the kitchen
when she heard another voice someone
said he's barely alive
he'll barely make it i assume they're
talking about chairman fred
pig said he's good and dead now
as they took me out and jammed a
revolver to my stomach
as i was handcuffed behind my back i
didn't look towards a
bedroom because i didn't know what i
would see or how i would respond
the police fired nearly 100 shots
fred hampton and mark clark were dead
the seven surviving panthers were
arrested
and police smiled as they removed
hampton's body
from the scene
the chicago police and the state's
attorney's office quickly shaped the
narrative
to call it a gun fight a battle and a
shootout
officers involved in the raid testified
that they were fired on from four
different rooms in the apartment by
shotgun
before i could get past the threshold
there were three shots
fired from the rear bedroom they played
back a story that
you could not even phantom they gave a
fictional account of what happened again
vilifying the black panther party
i mean they were firing at police yes
sir we saw the shots coming out of the
two bedrooms
this attack by the black panthers on the
police clearly demonstrates the true
character of the black panther party
but experts and lawyers hired by the
panthers along with other journalists
inspected the crime scene the panthers
even opened the apartment
so that anyone could examine it and a
drastically different picture emerged
it was clear that the police had fired
unprovoked
of the nearly 100 shots fired only one
possible shot could have come from a
panthers gun
likely from mark clark at the front door
the bullet holes that the police said
came from black panthers
were nail heads later it also emerged
that the fbi had assisted chicago police
with the raid
the fbi had an informant within the
black panther party
named william o'neill who had become
chief of security and hampton's
bodyguard
o'neil had provided the fbi with a
hand-drawn floor plan of the apartment
which the fbi then gave to chicago
police
and evidence strongly suggests that
before the raid
o'neill had drugged hampton
in the years after hampton's
assassination
the police and the fbi continued to
imprison
dozens of party members across the
country
the official black panther party would
continue to exist until 1982
but membership decreased dramatically
and
it would never be the same you know that
each one of you will be
died in international protest
revolutionary struggle
and i think that struggle is going to
come why don't you live for the people
why don't you struggle for the people
why don't you die
fred hampton wanted revolution those in
power
wanted to destroy him and what he stood
for
but they weren't totally successful
chairman fred lives you know what i'm
saying through the military assault
through the uh destruction of the party
as an organization itself you know by
the state
the legacy of the party is is still
still here
today the work of fred hampton is alive
through some of the same programs that
marked him
as a threat many of the programs that
the parents created
are now staples of our society we didn't
have free breakfast in schools prior to
the black panther party's free breakfast
program those free clinics almost every
major college campus got a free legal
aid clinic
the ways in which sickle cell testing is
now respected as a disease
by the cdc and others none of that stuff
existed before the party
i think that's revolutionary
the history of the black panther party
is going toe-to-toe with this government
will never die never die
thanks for watching this video if you
want to learn more about fred hampton
there's an amazing 1971 documentary
called the murder of fred hampton
available to stream via the chicago film
archives at the link in the description
they also have a film called american
revolution 2
which documents the work of the rainbow
coalition in action
and the many activists who helped to
spearhead the movement
thanks again for watching our piece and
stay tuned for one more episode in this
season of missing chapter